thank you thank you very much for being
here this afternoon yeah you mentioned
even two of those files will be able to
reach an agreement yesterday but there
was also another file about digitally
Europe program and once again just
yesterday we reached an agreement in
this very important issue so when
dealing with bookkeeping how I'm happy
to say that we were able to reach an
agreement with our 28 legislative files
out of 30 already I had to be happy and
I'm happy well about the copyrights
reform I'm I'm happy that we made a
really remarkable step forward so it was
quite complicated to manage with those
old-fashioned rules in digital area and
now we can say that in many areas people
they can have a look forward in a more
optimistic way I'm happy because of text
and data mining we can say that Europe
has leading position globally in meaning
of a scientific cut articles based based
on text and data mining but this is
mainly so because of the United Kingdom
because in the United Kingdom scientists
entrepreneurs they can fully use text
and data mining but in majority of EU
Member States this very important
instruments in is not in in hands of our
scientists and our entrepreneurs we have
a dream to have a leading position in
meaning of artificial intelligence
globally
but if our developers will not have this
really important instrument in their
hands how we will get this leading
position in the field of artificial
intelligence globally so according to
those new rules our scientists our
entrepreneurs they can use fully text
and data mining I am also happy because
of our digital cultural heritage as we
all know in our museums in our archives
they have already millions of hours of
cultural heritage which is recorded on
on tapes which is teach it all already
and at the same time we know also that
those TV series on tapes one day they
will just disappear
this information will disappear it will
not last forever that those tapes will
have really high quality and there is a
need we have to protect our cultural
heritage which is digital already for
this we have to make copies but to make
copies at first you had to clear rights
but just for one hour for TV series
there can be 200 different rights owners
and now there is a question to our
museums and archives have enough funds
to clear rights with 200 different
rights owners I don't think so so with
this new set of rules museums they can
make copies more easily
and we can say that yes our cultural
heritage which is digital already will
be preserved mandatory exceptions were
teaching purposes in the same story some
[Music]
university professors they have good
presentations somebody will invite them
to to deliver a lecture in another
country but professors they have some
doubts because they are using some kind
of copyrighted materials and when they
would like to go some other universities
in other countries they had to start
with from clearing rights of course they
have those three years to pay for filter
but it's it's too costly in meaning of
administrative cost it's it's about time
and energy you had to put in this
process and in many situations
professors they say now it's it's not
for me I prefer to stay at home so I'm
also happy that we were able to propose
something which will really help also
our creators I'm talking about fair
remuneration of our authors Article II
love article 11 and article 13 with
article 13 some people they say that
they are not able to understand about
what kind of value cap they are talking
about I'll try to explain once again
there are two types of platforms
platforms based on subscripts
they had in the year 2016 according to
McKinsey 212 million subscribers and
those 212 million subscribers say they
paid to musicians 3.9 billion u.s.
dollars globally musicians that they are
not totally happy but knowing that many
of those platforms based on subscription
are facing weather losses they had to
agree at the same time there are some
other platforms supported by ads those
platforms they had in the year 2016
even 900 million users but those
platforms paid to musicians just 553
million dollars and of course musicians
aren't happy they say look there is a
very low cap we expected to get 15
billion US dollars but we got just half
a billion dollars it's not fair
well some people representing those
platforms so they say that musicians so
they had to be happy because millions
and billions of people they can get
access to those masterpieces practically
immediately musicians they say of course
we are really happy because of the
internet but Farrell narration is also
important we have families they would
like to eat so we don't have to think
that all the musicians are they are just
stars
majority of of our creators they are
trying to survive and this fear
remuneration is is definitely important
also for those people who are in in
difficulties today article Avella 11
about neighboring rights press publishes
well in 1960s last century record labels
they cut their neighboring rights press
publishes they didn't get those
neighbouring rights yeah you can't agree
of course that there is no difference
between record labels and hand press
policies that's in fact yeah record
labels they had to invite drummers
singers somebody who is taking care
about recording to studio and press
publishes they had to invite journalists
photographers and somebody who is taking
care about layout not so big difference
why like record labels cut their
neighboring rights and press publishers
didn't get their neighborhood rights
because press policies they didn't ask
for those rights at that time it was
easier to say that we are just neutral
intermediaries and those photographers
journalists they have to reliable now
they aren't happy they say that somebody
else is using their content without
providing fair reminisce remuneration
for this well I think it's is fair
solution to provide also neighboring
rights to press publishes it will
definitely help them to create better
negotiating positions
in relations with the big platforms for
me it's really important to remember
that hyper linking will stay as one of
those basic freedoms we have in the
internet forever
it's not about link tax or or hyperlink
taxer but what they are talking about
it's about fair remuneration of course
we had tough negotiations and there were
a lot of tensions not only among those
colleges laters it was about all all the
interested groups in the same way but
result is is quite good it's a
compromise but it's a good compromise
I'm I'm not happy that with this really
important solution we were not able to
make happy everybody but I think
majority of people they are quite happy
with this solution once again a story
about Copenhagen and their Film
Institute once I was there there was a
lady sitting on my right hand she
delivered really impressive speech she
said distress I have this was really a
beautiful red dress I bought from
secondhand shop and I paid 25 Danish
crowns to get to this dress my car she
said is the oldest and ugliest car in
Copenhagen when
getting salary it's enough to pay back
those loans I took during the last year
month and next day I have to start with
new loans
please change existing copyright
legislation she got really strong
applause then a gentleman sitting on my
left hand he suit wasn't from
second-hand shop
he was producer he delivered also
impressive speech don't touch our
existing Papa rights legislation it
works well and he got salsa strong
applause then I thought why I had to be
here maybe making some hot talk with
each other so those tensions based on
different interests they will not
disappear with those rules but new rules
but I'm absolutely sure that those new
rules will create much better
environment for our creators and I would
like to say that those news rules will
provide us a much better protection to
our users for our users now there will
be much more clarity they can upload and
they don't have to be afraid that
uploading some kind of materials they
will get some punishment or whatever
licensing it's an obligation for
platforms not for users users are fully
protected well it was time for short
questions or also but I I thought that
my introductory words they will be short
so that question
so I've ready to take your questions and
there will be also technical brief and
and you can resolve all the question
about technicalities later on so when I
will leave this stage and it does not
mean but it's over
and no more information